[Music]
[Applause]
hi
everyone it seems to be working um yeah
so i'm here today to talk about
some of the extension mechanisms that we
have been built into to ggplot2
and maybe kind of demystify them a bit
in the process because i don't think
there are too many who knows about them
or at least knows how to do them
so i guess most of you use ggplot2 i
have used it but
just a quick show of hand who has uh
looked into extending gdpr too
well that's pretty nice that's more than
i expected so um
20 minutes is a precious little to talk
about the extension system because it's
it's big and it's sprawling and it's
uh somewhat complicated so i'm just
gonna give you
a quick overview about it and then in
the end i'm going to
to kind of point you in direction of
where to learn from more
and i'll of course be here and you can
talk to me all you want after the fact
so um ggplot2 has been gradually
expanding its extension mechanism
from the the point where it gets
introduced in gta plot 2 version 2.
uh before that it was kind of a here be
dragon situation if you wanted to
extend gdp plot 2 but at that point we
or hadley and winston at that time
decided to to kind of formalize all of
this
one of the reasons was that people kept
asking for new things in ggplot2 and
gdpr2 is already pretty big has been
discussed before
and it's simply not feasible for us to
include all possible
visualization possibilities into gta 2
itself it's much better to kind of
spread it out on
on multiple maintainers multiple
specific packages and so on so
the better extension system that we we
get the more is
simply possible for do for you guys um
there are a bunch of extensions point at
this moment um there's themes and
there's scales and there's yeah you can
see them all
up there they are not arranged kind of
uh randomly
because they are not equal there are
some that are
that simple to write and there are some
that are well
frightening and that's just how it is
because some things in visualization is
kind of frightening not in the sense
that you will
explode or whatever but it's just some
things are just
extremely uh extremely difficult to do
and facets is absolutely one of the the
worst things to do
so i'm not going to dive into that at
this moment um
further there are some other stuff there
are a guide system that is
being overhauled at this moment and
there is also a theme element so class
showed the element markdown theme
element and
it should work now but we're still in a
kind of a
phase where we're figuring out precisely
how we want to to approach this
so while you may be able to do it right
now and there are guide extensions but
they are not
kind of officially supported at the
moment so just
hold your horses for a bit with that if
you can and otherwise just be prepared
for breaking code at some point
um there is also a danger zone to be to
look out for so so these are actually
uh possible extension points uh you can
define what should happen when you
plus something to your gg plot for for a
new kind of object um
it is possible to define how the
rendering should happen
but this is definitely one of those here
be dragon things
you may want to do this is patchwork gta
animate
area like those could not work without
these kind of extension points
but it is also one of these things that
you can really blow up your package
and when we when we change something in
ggplot2 you may
have to to rewrite considerable amount
of code so
if you don't need it don't don't go
there
um so just to start off real quickly
with maybe the
easiest way to extend gta plot 2 is to
make a new theme
and new themes are really really
relevant like you can you can define
your theme for uh for
your cooperation or whatever and they're
really easy because
it's really just um ggplot2 code you're
you're used to defining themes when you
when you're doing your plots
and you can simply wrap that in a
function instead of using the plus mark
you use this replace operator but
other than that this is simply ggplot2
code as you're expected to
to look like and you can of course do
things that are much more interesting
than
putting a red background on your plot so
you can just go crazy there
but this is also like the extent of
normal code
that you'll see in extensions there's a
reason why i'm here and then talking to
you about this
because all the other things are
based on this this entity called ggproto
which is
yay another object-oriented system in r
um and gta proto is kind of this weird
object-oriented system
that is only relevant for ggplot2
extensions
um it is
it is tailor-made for ggplot2 uh the
reason why
it's something new is that it needed to
be a reference-based object-oriented
system and
the the current uh or that time current
object-oriented systems didn't allow
subclassing objects between packages so
if you want to make extensions of course
you need to be able to subclass between
ggplot2 and into your own package so
winston sat down and made something
new the good thing about this in some
sense is that gg proto is completely
hidden from the user so if this is the
first time
you hear about gg proto fear not this is
how it should be
but on the other hand it's also like
weird so when you want to transition
into writing extensions
uh you you come into this completely new
territory that you've never seen before
so code may look foreign to you because
it's it's a new system in some new
semantics but
but don't worry because it's not really
as bad as
as it uh should appear so basically gg
proto is this scaffolding thing that
that holds all of gt
plot together um and it is used to
orchestrate all the rendering and all
the
the mechanics of how ggplot uses your
data and transforms it into
into a into a plot so when you think
about how ggproto at least should be
used when you're writing uh
extensions to gta 2 and how gdp plot 2
uses it
itself is that you have to think about
gdproto classes as
somewhat of factories these are
these are classes that are stateless in
the sense that
you have uh you have an object and it
receives some data and it do something
to the data and it spits out the data
again
it doesn't keep track of what it has
been doing uh in that sense so
this is really important because when
you plot your your plot a second time
you don't want it to change you want it
to behave as
it should be every time you plug it so
so all of these tg proto
updates are more or less stateless there
are a few that you shouldn't touch that
are not stateless but for every
kind of idea of extensions you should
think of these as
as kind of factories you you have this
assembly line
and and each method is kind of a of this
this type of small robot arm or whatever
it doesn't change what it is doing to
between the different things that uh
that runs through the assembly line
and methods for these classes these they
span the assembly line so
so um a class is not
an object or a class it's not really an
area of the assembly line
they are grouped based on what type of
thing they are doing so
we have stat gdpr proto classes we have
geometric protoclasses
and they might go in at different times
in the rendering
and the rendering process and
and and do their thing so they they
might like in time or in in rendering
time they might
come in at different different points so
more formalized we have this idea that
we have
in generally uh in gt plot 2 we take
some data
we run it through some transformation
and there be a plot
and gd proto objects are really these
kind of entities that sits
at various points through this this
pipeline of data to plot
and they have methods and they modify
the data and then
some other object takes over and that's
modifying the data maybe spits it back
into the same object and so on and so
forth and then suddenly a plot disappear
appears hopefully not disappears
yes so there are a few things in
in the gt protoclasses that are
shared between a lot of the different
implementations and i'm just going to
point out a few of them i'm not going to
get
too much into exactly how you're going
to write a new faceting function or how
you're
going to write a new precision
adjustment or whatever but just kind of
highlighting a few of the things that
you might
potentially stumble into when you're
starting out with writing extensions
and one of the things that appears in
almost all of the different extension
points are these setup param methods
and and the reason why it's there is
because as i said
your objects are stateless but if you
want a state and usually you want
something
some kind of state based on the data
that you have in your plot this is where
you can get it
so this receives the data in the layer
and it receives it together with some of
the parameters that you have defined
when you
when the user calls the plot and it can
do whatever and it can spit out
a list of of parameters that the ggplot2
rendering system then takes hold of
so it's not changing this data search
but it is returning a list of parameters
that will get passed in
to other the other different methods so
it's kind of a pseudo
pseudostage um that that it
are able to do and one of the the places
where it's getting spit in again is this
in this
setup data method that a lot of the
different
methods has as well so it receives the
data as well and it receives these
parameters
that you have just uh calculated so it's
it's stateful but it's just handled
outside of the class
and what you can do in the setup data
stage is that you can re-parameterize
data which is actually kind of a a
powerful concept
there are a few geoms in ggplot2 which
kind of does the same thing
for instance you have gm segment and
then it's lesser well-known sibling
called gemspoke
and the only difference between these
two two gems is that
geom segments takes the the end points
of a segment and draws a line
while gm spoke takes a start point and
an angle and a length and draws a line
but behind it all everything it does is
really
geomespoke is a subclass of geom segment
and the only thing it does is it has a
setup data
which takes an angle a start point and a
length and calculate the new
endpoint and then everything else just
happens automatically
so if you have these kind of
re-permanentized
stats or geoms it's super simple to uh
to make an extension because
the only thing you have to think about
is to subclass it provide a new setup
data method and you're good to go
everything else will just happen
automatically
so this is a super important part and
you can really save yourself a lot of
work by just
thinking about whether some of the
things that you you want to achieve
is already handled by something else you
can also do
do stuff like make sure if there are
some columns that you need to have but
the user doesn't necessarily want to
uh define all the time you can just like
inspect your data and see well
does it miss the with column well okay
we'll set it to something
sensible and so on and just just make
sure that at this point the data kind of
makes sense for all of the remaining
remaining steps of the
of the object another quite important
thing especially when when it comes to
creating stats which is
kind of one of the best places to start
when creating extensions
is that the computation part like the
meat of a
of a stat element in ggplot2 is is this
kind of tired
succession of calls where you have you
have a compute layer
method and by default all it does is
it's
it's splitting up the layer data by the
panels and then it calls compute panel
and compute panel by default just splits
up the panel data by the group esthetic
and calls compute group so depending on
on where you want to sit in that in that
kind of succession you can define a
compute group method which is kind of
simple because you know you're only
getting data for a single group at a
time
and it may makes make it a lot easier to
kind of figure out your computations
but there's a lot of things that can be
vectorized in r
and it might be stupidly inefficient to
to compute the same thing per group
so you can just instead define a new
compute panel
method that does not call compute group
but does everything in one step
so you can you can it's usually easier
to start a computer
compute group level but you can quite
easily make your
your gems and stats more efficient by
thinking about how can we efficiently
do this in a vectorized manner um and
these compute things they simply just
take some data along with with
additional
parameters and it spits out a new data
frame so this is a very simple part of
this
this kind of assembly line where it just
takes data um
adds something to it or transform it in
some way and just spits out data again
for
for the assembly line to take over again
if you want to do a geom instead of a
stat
it's a bit different but kind of the
same idea we have a tied succession of
calls again and it's just draw layer
draw panel draw group
and again sometimes you can you can
vectorize things out and you can
really really speed up um your drawing
process for instance if you if you think
about the gm point
um if we had to draw each point
once like like one at a time and create
a
create a function that takes the group
and just draws one point one one at a
time it will
just be horribly inefficient but
thankfully grid that is uh
that is the motor behind ggplot2 can
just take a vector of point or
coordinates so we don't need to do this
per per group we can do this per panel
instead
and really like speed it up a thousand
fold or something like that
so again it's easier to start at the
group level but think about how you can
you can speed things up by vectorizing
it properly
and this takes in data again but this
does not output data
as cloud talked about there is this
concept of grub
in grids which is graphical objects and
the purpose of the draw method is simply
to return grubs that will then be
be rendered by grid in the end
there are a lot of other methods that
are that are being used all of them are
predefined you will usually not come up
with your own method you will override
the pre-existing ones and
and most of these have sensible defaults
and most of these you don't have to
worry about that much anyway
so in the end i'll just try to put this
into a
into effect and make an extension
and we'll do something as exciting as
drawing a circle because circles are
just the best um and when you start out
you will you just start to think about
well well how would i normally draw a
circle
what is what is the defining features of
a circle well you will have a midpoint
you will have a radius
and you will maybe remember from
uh geometry that a circle is defined by
uh zero to two times pi radians that is
kind of the
the different points along the the
periphery
and you can pre-compute some points
along the periphery and you can draw
this with gm polygon
and all works perfectly so when you're
in this situation then there's a lot
of extensions that are in this situation
like we want to draw some kind of shape
we want to draw some kind of line
well you don't have to think about how
to draw shapes and lines we already have
like
polygon functionality for this but we
want to take some sort of input
and we want to calculate it
out well inside the inside the rendering
code
then you're in the in the area of
creating a stat
because it takes input data and it and
it recreates
some new input some new output data that
can then be
be handled by geopolygon or whatever
so the first thing would probably be to
put all this into a function
so this is really just the same code
that i had before the the ggplot call
and and what it simply does it takes
some input and it calculates
it calculates the angles and creates a
data frame with the positions along
the periphery the reason why it's nice
to do this is that it's very easy to
reuse
it's much easier to debug because i
won't go into it but gg proto methods
are just horrible to debug
so you'd like to have the core
functionality nicely defined in
functions that you can
put browser in or debug them or whatever
it's also way easier to document so this
is just like good habit it's not
it's not necessary but but you'll thank
me at one point
so now we have everything we need and
we are ready to re to create our
extension and this is actually the
extension like it's it's pretty
pretty nice that you can have an
extension that just fits up
on one single slide this is a mouthful
and i'll go
through it um one of the things that you
you need to think about is that you'll
always
subclass existing classes so you'll
you'll very very seldom create a gt
proto
object from scratch uh if you want to
make a new stat you will subclass the
stat
the stat class or one of the other like
specified stat classes
and you want to piggyback as much as
possible i said that faceting for
instance is like like horribly
complicated
but you can you can subclass facet wrap
or facet grid and you can actually
kind of piggyback on all the complicated
stuff and do some pretty
amazing things without thinking too much
about the horrible stuff
so the first thing is the class
construction and we have this gigiproto
product function we name it we say
inherit it from stat and then we save it
to a stats
set circ and then we simply just define
our different methods we have the setup
data that we talked about
the only thing that's happening here is
that we want to ensure that a group
aesthetic
exists and that it is
that it is different for each row
because each row defines a circle
so we simply just make sure that that
happens um
and then we have the compute group as we
talked about and this simply just calls
our function
and that's more or less it and in the
end we also have some other things that
we can set we can
we can say well this statistic
statistics
require a certain uh number of
aesthetics here we say well
you need to specify x zero you need to
specify y zero you need to specify
an r otherwise this this step transform
will simply just
say don't want to do that um
so this is this is really it um the
reason why you you seldom see this type
of objects is of course that they are
they are packaged into nice little
containers
uh stat underscore circ for the circle
for this or gm underscore circle
i'm not going into these these are
really really simple to create but it's
just
a lot of a lot of scaffolding code and
you can just simply see how it's being
done
in gt plot 2 and it's it's really simple
it's just a lot of code so
i won't bore you with that so now we
have our circle
and does it work yes it does so as you
can see we can now
simply use our geom circle inside a
ggplot2 call and it behaves as we expect
it to
and the nice thing about this is that
this now functions
with all the different things that you
expect in ggplot2 so you can do faceting
you can do whatever and all that
as i said this is a very very brief
overview
um one of the things that i want to
emphasize is that
the the ggplot2 book which has been on
sale uh
for a long time we're working on the
third edition it's going to be free as
most of the our other books so you can
already see it here uh gdpr plot twos
book. and i'm working on an actual
chapters
uh talking a bit about extensions going
into more details about how you will
approach this
and thankfully we also have a huge
community of people that that are
building extensions and a lot of these
are
are based on or are referenced in this
ggplot2 dash
x dot org
webpage and like the best way to learn
is simply by example so there is a lot
of examples of creating
like both super easy extensions and more
hairy and gnarly ones
so just go there and look and otherwise
talk to me because
i'm happy to answer your questions
that's it
okay that actually takes us straight
into the break
but where can uh you be found if people
want to ask you questions
here around okay please on twitter as
well of course
all right thank you everyone thanks for
attending this session and please
enjoy the coffee break